hey friends and welcome back to Deep
dive the weekly podcast where it's my
immense pleasure to sit down with
authors and academics and entrepreneurs
and creators and other inspiring people
and we find out how they got to where
they are and what strategies and tools
and principles we can learn from them to
help us build a life that we love now we
have reached the end of season five
already absolutely mental this podcast
has now been going on for the last year
and a half which feels like an
absolutely long time but also feels like
just yesterday that we had the idea for
the podcast and then had our first few
guests and kind of started getting the
ball rolling and figuring out how to
make a podcast how to do multicam edits
how to do shorts for social media all of
that fun stuff but the main benefit of
the podcast is I feel like through
having all of these conversations which
you guys have been very kindly listening
to and watching and commenting on and
everything I've learned so much about
myself and so much that I've applied to
my own life and my own business as well
now one of the things that I've been
really focusing on for this particular
season of the podcast is health and
relationships I think on the work front
most of what I read and consume and
listen to and watch anyway is business
and work related but I chronically under
best in my health and in relationships
and in consuming content and learning
about those sorts of things and so in
particular I took a lot of lessons away
from the episode that we did with John
and Julie gottman who are like one of
the most famous people in the world when
it comes to relationship advice and
that's been super helpful and I've
already started applying some of the
stuff from that episode to my
relationship and then similarly in
improving the relationship that I have
with myself the episode that I did with
a psychologist Dr Arya felt more of a
therapy session than I did a podcast
episode and I took away so much from
that and actually Dr Ari and I had a
kind of private coaching session
afterwards which we might release
because we filmed it at some point if
you guys are potentially interested but
that was also super valuable in kind of
helping me feel more self-confidence and
more self-love as well now this episode
is going to be our usual end of season
Roundup where we're going to play seven
different clips from seven different
episodes of the podcast for this last
season and these are specific actionable
takeaways that you can take from some of
the episodes I'd also like to say a
massive thank you at this point to
everyone who has signed up to podcast
who has subscribed on YouTube or on
Spotify on iTunes or wherever you get
your podcast this season we hit 200 000
drivers on the YouTube channel which is
absolutely insane and it's been really
nice and heartwarming getting comments
via email and the YouTube comments and
even on your telegram Community hearing
how much some of you guys have enjoyed
the podcast and the actionable takeaways
you've taken from it on that note if you
would like to join our telegram
Community it's completely free there'll
be a link down in the video description
or in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this and
that's where we post behind the scenes
stuff from the podcast and if I have a
guest coming on and curating questions
from the audience the telegram Community
is where we go to get those questions
anyway that's enough talking from me
let's now roll the seven lessons for the
Roundup of season five of the podcast I
hope you enjoy them at the moment
according to the YouTube analytics 81 of
you who are watching this on YouTube
have not yet hit the Subscribe button
and so if you're for example in the now
81 of people who are watching this on
YouTube but who are not subscribed to
the channel I would love it if you could
do so and would be awesome to get that
number down to 50 and it would be cool
to get like 50 50 sub non-sub ratio just
just for fun other optimizations that
healthy people without gut problems can
make to improve like productivity
performance that kind of thing yeah for
sure so if you got is not quite working
optimally then that can even though you
might not have any specific symptoms it
can still have an impact on your mental
health and your mental performance right
so your gut is such an integral part of
your whole body system and ecosystem and
inevitably if it's not happy it's going
to be screaming at your brain all the
time and that is noisy and difficult for
your brain to cope with and that can
lead to things like brain fog and
struggling with focus and concentration
for example similarly if your gut isn't
happy but you don't really know from
other symptoms but you're getting loads
of bugs infections viruses all the time
you notice you're really susceptible
that's a good time to start looking at
your gut health and I think I guess for
this audience what's really important to
recognize is this connection between
your gut and your brain and how they are
constantly communicating with each other
for better or worse so there is a very
strong line of communication between
your gut and your brain which we refer
to as the gut brain axis and again they
are chemically connected through
neurotransmitters that are produced in
the gut they are hormonally connected by
the HPA axis and they are physically
connected by the vagus nerve and the
chattiest organ between your brain and
your gut is your gut your gut is
constantly telling your brain all sorts
of different things and throwing
messages up that it's got to deal with
and people might think oh it's your
brain you've got it's not really doing
anything but actually your brain is busy
and it's communicating and it's a lot
through those microbes that live in your
colon
sick
you're very good at this thanks it's not
my first time you've got the whole like
it's like wow
um so what can I do for example as a
proxy for people listening to this
my poo is fine once a day you know
medium brown color not overly smelly I
think but everyone like the smell of the
red poo apparently
um but
obviously I want to kind of maximize my
performance and my focus and actually
one question we we get so often from our
audience is people struggling to focus
and I think often people are like I
struggle to focus on my schoolwork or
with my whatever
web design side hustle I must have ADHD
as like an immediate option but I wonder
if there's gut stuff we can do before we
get to that point yeah definitely I mean
your gut health is so because your your
gut is constantly communicating with
your brain again if your gut is not
happy things are communicating
differently but also you could just not
be producing enough serotonin for
various different reasons or your gut
might not be sending the right signals
up to your brain so you might have if we
looked at your microbiome and it's
certainly not necessary to do that we
can do this in clinic without testing
but if we looked at your microbiome we
might find that you've just not got
enough of these bacteria that are doing
this particular important job with brain
connection stuff
um so what we would suggest then is to
really optimize the gut and you know
what happens Ali as you know is when
people are busy and they're working too
hard and they're doing a side hustle and
everything else is high pressure or
they've got a family and everything else
people tend to make their diet quite
small and not necessarily in terms of
volume but the types of foods that
they're eating so they might end up
eating the same types of foods on repeat
what I see is people there's kind of two
camps here the people who do like the
meal prep stuff and they eat the same
Foods five days a week and I think
they're being super healthy eating sweet
potato and broccoli every day or you
have the people who are just living meal
to meal prep you know Etsy wherever
they're going every day the same sorts
of things but just various different
places and nothing's particularly
planned or thought through and
inevitably both of those ways of eating
have an impact on your gut health
whether you feel it in your gut or not
so that way of eating limits the types
of fibers that you'll get bacteria being
fed and the most important thing for
your gut health is that you're eating 30
different plants a week so trying to eat
loads of variety of different types of
plants that includes fruit and veg but
also nuts and whole grains different
types of grains we're super fixated in
this country on like oats and wheat but
actually there's so many different types
of grains that our gut really benefits
from
so when you're busy and you're
struggling and you're eating meal to
meal or you're eating the same Foods on
repeat what happens is you've got Health
you've got sort of function might not
change but your gut health is inevitably
not optimized and that's when you can
have these problems with lack of
concentration Focus energy getting bugs
all the time that kind of stuff and
really interestingly your gut bacteria
communicate with your hypothalamus so
that bit of your brain that controls
things like cortisol production so
really early in your life your gut
bacteria dictate where your sort of HPA
axis is set so how much core style you
release in under given circumstances and
we all need some cortisol right but we
don't want loads and loads of cortisol
because we've got loads of anxiety and
stress all the time we can really
struggle to concentrate and to focus so
we can use our gut bacteria to try and
reduce that and make things a little bit
better in that department we can use
them and harness their powers to get
more serotonin which helps us with
better sleep and concentration and focus
and all those important things those
happy hormones and we can also just try
and calm down those messages from our
gut to our brain which are distracting
our brain all the time and your gut
bacteria are going to be saying we need
more plants and you're going to be not
reading that properly and giving them
more Sushi and that's not quite what
they want wow so
it sounds like you're saying please
correct me if this is an
oversimplification that changing up what
you eat can have a massive impact on
your
Focus productivity performance happiness
absolutely because all of those things
are linked gut brain everything yeah
fundamentally I mean and proven in
amazing research in science yeah what
kind of research has been done on this I
guess I'm I'm thinking healthy people
rather than people with official gut
problems yeah so uh the amazing work of
John cryen is a really good place to to
start looking at this stuff if people
are interested and he's written an
amazing book called The psychobiotic
Revolution so psychobiotics are these
gut bacteria that communicate with our
brain so they're the ones that we're
particularly interested in when we
develop the height smart probiotic for
example so work that's been done in that
area to start with inrodent models they
used a model of an autistic mouse and a
model of a non-autistic mouse or a
sociable Mouse and they took the
microbiome so they took a sample and and
gave the microbiome of the autistic
Mouse to the sociable Mouse and the
sociable Mouse starts to show autistic
traits okay and when they swap them over
the autistic Mouse starts to become a
sociable Mouse just because it's got
microbiomas changed so that was the
early work that they did trying to
understand how much our gut microbiome
is impacted impacting our mental health
our mental performance how our brain is
working so similar studies to that have
then been replicated in humans in other
places and to be clear that autistic
Spectrum Disorder stuff in humans is so
complex and we can't replicate that
exactly in humans as yet but there's
certainly something going on there which
is what we generally learn from rodent
studies we've also got some great data
showing things like increase in
production of Serotonin when we use
particular probiotic species there's
great data showing that using particular
probiotic species within treatment diets
and things like that so within treatment
within studies in controlled studies
improves anxiety depression all of these
kinds of symptoms and wider nutrients
within this world if we think about
things like Omega-3s and B vitamins
they've been used in place of anxiety
and depression medications ssris that
kind of stuff and they work as
effectively in some people some of the
time I'm in study so we can use all of
these things and a similar work has been
done with the two straight or two of the
strains we use in the smart probiotic in
terms of seeing whether they work as
effectively as common anti-depression
anti-anxiety medications and they do so
much so that there's Health claims on
them in Canada that people can say these
are definitely shown to improve anxiety
and depression
so there's great data it's a young field
of research but it's super exciting and
it's very solid research just showing
that the magic that we can harness from
our gut if someone was being like okay
Sophie how do I how do I change my diet
such that it improves my brain function
or makes me have improves my mood what
are like the top recommendations here
yeah great question so
um Omega-3s are super super important
for our brain structure as we've talked
about and they can also help to protect
us from excess inflammation in the brain
which is linked to anxiety and
depression and stuff like that so either
make sure you're having at least two
portions of oily fish a week or take
care Omega-3 supplements B vitamins are
incredibly important for our brain
health they they produce they make
things like serotonin melatonin all of
our they make dopamine Gaba all of these
really important brain chemicals that we
really need all the time so B vitamins
are really essential for brain function
and we've got some really interesting
work showing that you can use B vitamins
in controlled circumstances in
replacement of ssris so anxiety and
depression treatments and they will work
in a very similar way in the right doses
at the right moment for the right people
so be vitamin is super super important
for General brain function and brain
health and then we also think about
things like antioxidants and
particularly the anthocyanins from
blueberries are amazing for our brain
health so not just blueberries but
anthocyanins come in like red cabbage
other dark purple vegetables and there's
some amazing data showing that if
children are given a blueberry smoothie
before an exam they perform better in
that exam than the children who haven't
had a blueberry smoothie and then when
we swap them over and the level of the
exam stays the same and the first
children are given the blueberry
smoothie not going to be with me second
or an R the children who had the
blueberry smoothie always perform better
than the children who didn't have the
Booboo smoothie so what we think is
happening there is it's getting better
blood to your brain and that is meaning
that you can have a better mental
performance in a very like short like
period of time so it's having that
direct impact on your brain health in
that moment that thing that you just
said I imagine there are some people
listening to this thinking oh my
God that sounds incredible and just as
many probably thinking oh my God
that sounds like the worst thing in the
world this guy's a psychopath like
um I wonder like I mean most people do
the same thing but with music
right so let's take Hamilton for example
um I eat biographies for breakfast I'm
obsessed right like I literally wrote a
rap album about the life of Arnold
Schwarzenegger after I listened to
Hamilton for the first time
um Hamilton the musical it's about two
hours 40 minutes long it is the best
biography of Hamilton in my opinion
right it's dramaticized but like you
can't take away from the beat and lyrics
and everything else when you listen to
music it's exactly like listening to a
book especially if you pay attention to
the lyrics by the way one really cool
thing is if you start listening to a lot
of audiobooks you will notice and
remember all the lyrics from all the
songs you listen to most people who I am
friends with
um you know they listen to the beat or
the melody and they don't necessarily
recall or understand the lyrics they
need to look at the lyrics on their
phone to really and take them for me
like both happen because I've trained
that part of my brain
but if you already do this for music why
do you do it with music because it
enriches your life It Makes You Happy
Well Brandon sanderson's uh you know the
way of Kings enriches my life I'm sorry
even more than music and so again it
doesn't matter if it's fantasy or
fiction or philosophy or sci-fi I listen
because it makes me happy it's it's
beautiful it's enjoyable I'm living
inside this world and the joy that you
get from a book if you've read a book
is so much deeper than the Joe you get
from watching a movie or watching a TV
series and so I don't watch TV I don't
watch movies I just consume books but I
do it with my ears
do you like uh presumably on on the few
occasions where you do watch TV movies
YouTube videos do you speed those up as
well or do you sort of slow it down and
watch it as the Director pre intended or
some like that I cannot deal with
the speed of movies and TV shows at this
point so I use an app on my on my
computer called uh
video speed controller uh you can
increment the speed by 0.1 increments
and when like my friends don't notice I
I up it by 20 but if I was watching by
myself I'd watch to do by 5x speed
YouTube on my computer automatically
plays a 3X speed for everything
um and again okay we talked about you
know working out right before this when
I was younger
you know lifting 145 pounds was
difficult now
I can bench press that however long you
want me to
um and so you build the muscle right if
you build the muscle and you can bench
press like 225 easy
um there's no reason to set the
resistance to 145 set it to 25. and so
the trick is just practice listening
faster and here's the key
some of us are able to read at a
thousand words per minute like there are
people who can do this right a college
professor in the United States typically
will read about a 330 350 words per
minute no one goes how dare you read
that quickly
it's the same thing it's just that the
upper level that is accessible to most
people and listening is a lot easier to
reach and here's why
we've been listening for hundreds of
thousands of years
we've only been reading
for like a thousand years
we evolved to be really good at
storytelling and paying attention and
processing with our ears
it's a hack you know the idea of writing
characters and then decoding them it's
an amazing hack but it's a hack
um it's not what humans evolved to learn
how to do
if you learn and here's the thing right
reading is a highly computational
behavior for the brain to do typically
about 97 of your brain function is
actually working on decoding and only
three percent can focus on comprehension
but if you listen like three percent is
focusing on decoding 97 focus on
comprehension so computers
are designed for computing the really
good at Computing and so if you could
Outsource the computational work
of reading to a computer that's the best
except AI was not good enough to read
like a human until
just about now
um and so now you can do that just think
about it this way right how many of us
do long division math in our head nobody
you pull up your iPhone you do it on
your phone
it makes sense to do the same thing with
reading
um do you listen to podcasts very much
I didn't used to and the quality of
podcasts significantly increased over
the last 10 months so now I do my
favorite is how to take over the world
by Ben Wilson
oh my God it's amazing
okay so I came up I came across this
podcast
the first episode I listened to was uh
the life of Julius Caesar uh and then I
listened to Napoleon's biography by him
and then he recently put out the
biography of
um Brigham Young
and what he'll do is he'll read like
five primary sources and he'll produce
like a two to three hour uh biography
podcast he's got a great voice and then
he'll also find the overarching concepts
from all their lives for example they
all eat fast they all attack fast
they're all really good at communication
and it's fascinating and so you know I
love the idea of taking over the world
not in the same violent way that people
used to but there's a lot that you can
learn so I'm obsessed with Hamilton I'm
also obsessed with Napoleon
um and you know Sandy for Julius Caesar
and so the more you study people the
more interesting it is and so that the
reason why I didn't like podcasts
historically is you know you got one
person interviewing another person
another person editing basically three
human hours run into one minute of you
consuming but if I fly from like
California to New York and I listen to
the
book Obama row before he became
president that book is eight hours long
I listen to 2x speed 3x speed by the
time I land I finish that book it's like
I sat next to Obama the entire time but
he spent an hour thinking about every
single minute of what he was going to
say
and so books used to be a more dense
source of information uh podcasts
recently have improved dramatically the
other thing that happened to me is that
now read enough books that it's actually
difficult for me to find new things in
books but the lead time from something
being discovered
to appearing in a podcast is faster than
the lead time for something being
discovered to be published in a book and
so when I was in college uh I knew I was
in the right classes when I started not
being able to Wikipedia the concepts
about photovolithics engineering that we
were learning in class and I could only
learn that from the professors directly
and so what I did is I took all these
classes and I would email professors at
Stanford and MIT and Harvard to like ask
them additional questions
um it's now become the case that for
most topics you can learn more Cutting
Edge stuff from podcasts so that's
really cool
yeah
interesting that's a good way of
thinking about it um the way I think
about audiobooks versus podcasts is
audiobooks are really good if I want to
get like a just a broad General like
sort of Blitz about about a particular
topic but one thing I like about
podcasts is that usually like for
example if Tim if Tim Ferriss is an
interviewing Morgan house all about the
psychology of money like the book is
good but in a way him asking questions
to the thing will spark other things in
my mind of like even though I've read
the book I still find the interview
valuable or I can't one when Cal Newport
is interviewing Tim Ferris about
something I'm very familiar with both of
their work and so the way they talk
about it as a meta level of awareness to
the topic but there's no point me
listening to a podcast about nuclear
because I know nothing about the topic
and so to get the foundational
groundwork the books are sick and then
at that point I can understand what the
experts are talking about
and then the other thing I would say is
amazing about books is if you listen to
fantasy or sci-fi World building it's
really difficult to build a world and
have it be
um
congruent and consistent and actually
there's a lot of strategy in doing that
and so you get a lot of emotional
rewards uh by listening to a fantasy or
sci-fi audiobook that someone has spent
a lot of time thinking about
I'd love to talk a little bit about the
new book uh the love prescription seven
days to more intimacy connection and joy
I've started reading that on my Kindle
and I've got the physical copy arriving
in the next in the next couple of days
um but it's interesting because one of
the one of the claims in the book or at
least in the in the blurb is that there
is a formula for a good relationship and
if you just I almost the vibe that I got
was that hey if you follow the formula
and just do these seven things across
these seven days or however however long
it takes you will just almost magically
improve the quality of your relationship
uh so I wonder if you can just kind of
Riff on that a little bit like what is
this formula for love
yeah
sure so one of the things is being nice
to one another
so yeah all right giving a part of
compliments uh you know uh catching your
partner doing something right and and
communicating that communicating respect
and affection and words letting your
partner know how attractive they are to
you and how irresistible they seem at
times you know those that kind of
positivity is very very critical
another one is
turning toward it turns out to be a very
powerful thing in a relationship so you
know in our apartment lab what we saw
130 newlywed couples and followed them
for six years
we discovered that a lot of time when
they're just kind of hanging out in this
apartment lab one person will try to get
the other person's attention or share
something humorous or you know some
interesting story that they've heard or
are reading about and then they try to
connect they make the bid for connection
and then the cameras in the lab always
swung to the other person to see the
response and there were one of three
responses turning toward which was you
know really acknowledging the connection
you know one person might say Oh What a
Beautiful boat that is you know going by
and if the other person said yeah huh uh
that was turning toward if they didn't
respond at all that was turning away or
if they responded irritably would you be
quiet I'm trying to read that was
turning against
so when we followed couples the the 17
couples who divorced one another after
uh six years after the wedding uh when
we looked back six years earlier they
had turned toward these bids only 33 of
the time
whereas the couples who are still
together
six years earlier had turned toward the
bids 86 percent of the time
you know a huge difference
and we also discovered that turning
toward is like an emotional bank account
that you build when you really connect
with your partner when your partner
wants to connect with you then
during conflict
you have more of a sense of humor about
yourself and about one another you can
laugh together and you can be
affectionate even when you disagreeing
and it reduces physiological arousal so
turning toward is another one that's
very very powerful and when people
become aware of that as a tool of
connecting then the relationship
improves quite dramatically right so in
this book what we're doing is each day
we're giving couples little thing to do
little ten minute thing to do every
single day like one day we'll be giving
compliments you know really expressing
fondness and admiration a second day
will be look for what your partner is
doing right
and not just wrong right and point it
out and say thank you to your partner
you know third is listening you know
talking about your needs with one
another what do you need and we
emphasize you should bring up your needs
as a positive need rather than a
negative need and what that means is
that you ask for what you do want
not what you don't like or you resent
don't bring that up because that's going
to sound like criticism instead flip it
on its head and say I would love it if
you clean the dishes three times a week
that would be such a big help to me
that's a positive mean so uh people
present you know on I forget which day
they talk about one need they have with
their partner that can allow their
partner to shine for them
it's not a criticism it's the opposite
right another one is honoring each
other's dreams so talk about what maybe
deeply hell dream you have for something
you want to do something you want to
experience something you want to feel
whatever it is
share that with your partner and really
listen to what your partner says about
that question too
so you know there what we hope to see if
people practice this every day for seven
days is that from before they started it
to the end of the week they'll see a
little bit of change maybe little
something feels different and they can
talk about which one of those little
prescriptions really made a difference
for them
now it doesn't mean everything gets
fixed in seven days and then you can go
back to being whoever you were before no
it's instead that you're learning how to
do something a little different that
deepens the Friendship deepens emotional
intimacy which of course opens up to you
know what you know more sexual intimacy
and helps you when you have to talk
about conflict continue those practices
especially the ones you found the best
for you and your partner
and you'll see over time you know the
relationship is doing this over time big
change all right we're just going to
take a quick break from the podcast to
introduce our sponsor which is very
excitingly heal I have been a pain
customer of huel since 2017 so it's been
about six years now that I've been using
Hill fairly regularly I started eating
Hill in my fifth year of medical school
and I've been using heel regularly ever
since because you know I like to be
productive I you know my calendar is
full with a lot of things and often I
don't have the time or don't make the
time to have a particularly healthy
breakfast or a particularly healthy
lunch my favorite flavor is salted
caramel because 400 calories you get 40
grams of protein which is absolutely
insane and you also get a decent healthy
mix of carbohydrates and fiber and fat
along with 26 different vitamins and
minerals which are all very good for the
body there's nine different flavors of
this to choose from my favorite is a the
banana version and also the Salted
Caramel version so what I do is I take
my two scoops I put them into my
NutriBullet blender type thing although
you can just use a normal Shaker if you
want I mix it up normally with water but
a little bit of milk to add a bit more
of a milkshake like consistency to it
and then I to sip that while I'm on my
desk doing my work in the morning and it
ensures that I get a very healthy
breakfast in that's nutritionally
complete rather than some high sugar
cereal which is what I would have
defaulted to instead also heel is
ridiculously reasonably priced like a
meal 400 calories comes out to one pound
68 per meal which is super super cheap
compared to what the alternative would
be if you were ordering takeout for
example anyway if you like the idea of
getting these cheap and healthy and
nutritionally complete meals in your
diet then head over to heal.com forward
slash Deep dive and if you use that URL
heal.com forward slash Deep dive they
will send you a free t-shirt which are
quite nice and also a free kind of
shaker bottle type thing with your first
order so thank you so much Hill for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you can invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you the app also lets you
Auto invest which is a great thing
because then you can automatically
invest a percentage of your paycheck
into the thing every month and so if you
haven't yet started with investing and
you want to give it a go then you can
download the app on the App Store and if
you use the coupon code Ali Ali at the
checkout that will give you a totally
free share worth up to 100 pounds it's
available on iPhone and Android and you
can check it out by typing in trading212
into your respective App Store so thank
you so much trading212 for sponsoring
this episode in a successful couple
here's what they do the minute they
sense that they're getting flooded in
fight or flight one of them will call
for a break and and say when they ask
for a break when they'll come back to
talk about the conversation you know
that topic again so they'll say
something like honey I I've got to take
a break I'll be back in an hour then
let's talk again
that way they don't leave the other
person feeling abandoned and not knowing
if they're ever going to talk about it
again then when the partners separate
into separate quarters
they each do something that is
self-soothing
not think about the fight because if
they think about it they'll stay
escalated but do something else distract
yourself read a magazine a book listen
to music meditation go for a run you
know all kinds of things you can do to
self-soothe take a bath and then come
back at the designated time when you're
calmer and a way to tell if your calmer
is take your heart rate and if your
heart rate is back down to normal then
you're good if it's not back go back to
your partner anyway and ask for more
time
give a second time you'll return until
you can talk calmly with one another and
the conversation will look like you've
just had a brain transplant your latest
book some days today which is sick is I
guess on the surface a productivity book
and there are some people that like oh
productivity is for losers productivity
is all about just like grinding yourself
to the ground and not having any fun uh
but you don't strike me as that kind of
guy so what I guess what's your broad
approach to these goals and to
productivity in general
I like to think that productivity is
really dream oriented that
everyone should have a dream and if they
don't they probably do and they're not
admitting to it or they do that terrible
thing where they don't actually spend
time thinking about themselves one of
the tragedies of the world is we spend
all of our time thinking about our
parents and our spouses and our children
and our business and our clients and our
customers but it's very rare that
someone sits down and just says I'm
going to think about me for a little
while how I got here you know where am I
going what are my goals as a Storyteller
I'm obsessed with finding stories so I
have something new to say on stage so
storytellers tend to be deeply curious
about themselves we're self-centered in
what I say is a positive way just
meaning we afford ourselves times to
think about us so in terms of
productivity you first have to have the
dream or a multitude of dreams you have
to have a horizon that's when I like to
think of it as what's your horizon
what's the point on the horizon but that
point on the horizon can be I've always
wanted to have a backyard vegetable
garden you know or I was talking to a
client the other day and I said well
what's your horizon goal and she said I
want to see the 50 great latest movies
of all time there's a list in the world
I'd have the list and I want to sit on
my couch and watch the 50 greatest
movies she said but that doesn't feel
super productive and I said that sounds
incredibly productive to me because it's
your dream so when people say
productivity sort of grinds you down I
think of productivity is it's the thing
that you want to be doing that you
should be doing more of so let's
maximize our life the things we have to
do in order to sustain life in order to
get to the things we want to do so we
don't have to think of productivity in
terms of work we can if you're one of
those people who have enormous work
dreams and and money dreams and how
streams and vacation dreams that's great
like those are all valuable goals if
that means something to you but if your
goal is to sit on the couch more and
watch black and white movies with your
husband and make sure you see all of
them before you die all the ones you're
supposed to see that's a wonderful goal
let's make sure we maximize your work
time your our chore time let's take away
all of those little black holes of your
life that you're wasting and make sure
that we use all that so you can get your
ass on the couch more often with your
husband watching black and white movies
I think that's the way to dispel that
productivity nonsense which is we have
to grind ourselves it's just dream
oriented choose the right dream
and then productivity will make total
sense to you that's nice I like that
terminology like all right what's your
horizon goal um and I guess
we can have Horizon goals for different
areas of our life like if I imagine for
like my book The Horizon goal is oh
actually brought more more broadly I'd
like to be an author who writes books
every few years because it seems kind of
fun
um and then I guess I can break that
down into more concrete steps like is
that how you approach it you figure out
the Horizon goal and you break it down
like what's what's your process for this
yeah well I like a horizon goal because
I think that
you know if we're thinking about a dream
or that thing on the horizon I think
when people Define it very specifically
it's a mistake you know I originally
thought I was going to be a Storyteller
who told stories on stages in New York
and Boston and maybe somewhere else in
the world and if I had made that Horizon
Point sort of defined and specific I
would have only moved in that direction
I like thinking of Horizons because
that it's sort of very wide it's a
distant point that you can't quite see
it's the acknowledgment that the road
you're on the path you're taking might
not actually land you and the place you
thought you would land but you'll land
in the vicinity it's an it's an
approximation of the dream you know even
with sort of a book I start writing a
novel it always starts with a what if
question and I think I know what the end
is going to be it never has been the end
I allow the book to sort of dictate
where the where the final moment of this
character is going to be and I just see
it as a horizon but sometimes I go wow
that was quite left of whatever I
thought it was going to land but it's in
the vicinity it's not behind me it's
always somewhere in the front so I like
to identify that idea of I'm going to be
a Storyteller but that I'm going to be a
Storyteller also allows because it's on
the horizon to be maybe I'll teach
storytelling someday maybe I'll be a
consultant about storytelling maybe
maybe an advertising company will allow
me to inject storytelling into their car
commercial which is what I've done right
all of those things are sort of on the
storytelling Horizon but it affords me
the opportunity to be flexible in terms
of what ultimately is going to happen
okay so let's say I have which I sort of
do a horizon goal of I'd like to be a
musical performer of some kind
um I did this was actually when I you
know back in like 2008 when I discovered
YouTube uh the channels I was mostly
following were the YouTube music cover
artists and I'd watch them play the
piano or the guitar and sing along to
some cover of a popular song and think
damn that's sick I really want to do
something like that and I had a few full
Stars I dabbled with a few videos here
and there over the years and it was only
like 10 years later that I was like you
know what let me sit down and teach what
I know about how to get into med school
that I actually became a YouTuber so it
sort of ended up going in a completely
different direction but I have always
had in the back of my mind that
at some point someday
um I would like to
um oh yeah I'd I'd like to explore that
interest a little bit more I love the
idea of learning how to play instruments
myself and learning music theory and
learning how to compose and arrange and
then singing either myself or with
friends to two popular songs so that's
like a vague Horizon go I guess like I
like that yeah yeah that makes sense to
me yeah yeah in terms of breaking it
down or like yeah what's the process
well it sounds to me like you're not
quite sure like what
you know path that's you're going to
take to the Horizon and I and I like
that too you know I think the mistake
people would make would be I am going to
get a record contract I am going to be a
lead singer in a rock band with a record
contract that is a bad idea I think what
you've said is I want to do something in
music and I kind of want to be a person
maybe making music and making people
happy with that music right but if that
Horizon means you know what I discovered
I'm actually a really good DJ I don't
need to learn how to play a music
because I can actually scratch and that
actually fills that need for me or it
could be turns out I can't play
instruments but what I can do is I can
find people who play them really well
and I can help them make better music
and become a music producer right that's
that's in that general area and I think
it's when people say no I will not be
happy unless I have a record contract
and I'm in a rock band and I'm
performing in arenas that's the only
thing that's going to make me happy
I think that's a terrible sort of
approach to life so I like your approach
which is I kind of want to do something
in music I think I want to play music
but you know open to other things and
then I would just do what you're doing
which is begin the exploration start
walking down the path you know all right
let me try a guitar for a while right my
wife wanted to play the guitar and then
she quickly realized you know what the
ukulele is better than the guitar it's
easier to play it's smaller and I can
use it in my kindergarten classroom so
she became a ukulele player she's pretty
good and and then one day I said are you
ever gonna sing with the ukulele and she
said I don't know I'm not that good of a
singer but it turns out with the ukulele
it doesn't demand you to be a good
singer because the instrument is so sort
of
small and light and amusing that you
don't have to sort of sing really
beautifully you can just sing well so
she has become a ukulele player who
plays music to her kindergarten students
and changes the way they learn because
of it not her original goal which is I
want to play the guitar someday but it's
become this thing and all she did was
she started on the path she took
positive steps forward most people spend
an enormous amount of time thinking
about what they should do to get to the
Horizon rather than saying well this is
one possible step I could take I'm going
to take the one possible step and if
it's not the right one I will take
another possible step but I cannot tell
you how many people I meet who say well
I'm still trying to plot out my thing
and I always say all the thinking you're
doing about reaching your goal is
meaningless and useless and it doesn't
count for anything if you're just
thinking about getting there you're
doing nothing take a step forward even
if that means going online and buying a
ukulele that's the first step grade you
made a positive step today a ukulele is
coming to your home think about what the
next thing you can do is you know the
idea of incrementalism is so important
people don't believe in it the idea that
tiny changes accumulated over time
produce enormous results most people
want a Big Gulp a magic pill they want
to instantly have a million subscribers
they want to have a perfect YouTube
video they want to have a book contract
before they actually write the book or
even before they even write the proposal
right everyone sort of wants this
enormous leap and if you examine the
success stories which I always believe
you should do is like just examine the
success stories of people in the world
so that you can get a sense of what
those success stories are all of them
involve tiny incremental changes piling
up over time that eventually produce
enormous results but people don't
believe in it because they can't see it
immediately you know I just recently
started I learned that people who have
better balance live longer because if
you get older and you don't have good
balance you fall and those Falls put you
in the hospital and old people in the
hospital die you you know that probably
better than I do and so one of the
tricks I Learned was when you're
brushing your teeth stand on one foot
during the first minute of brushing your
teeth and see if you can maintain that
one foot and then switch to the other
one and so I've started doing that and
I've asked people or I've told people
this is a really good idea you know to
help you improve your balance and
someone came back to me and said after a
month well I don't really see my balance
improving
and I said well first of all you didn't
really gauge your balance you didn't
assess your balance on day one to day
30. so it's impossible for you to even
say that but I said this is incremental
change you're not even supposed to see
it you're not even supposed to expect to
see it you just have to believe that
every single day that you spend a minute
on each foot twice a day if you're
brushing your teeth twice a day which
you should be
over time the piling up of small things
will produce enormous results but you
can't expect to see the results
immediately and if you do
that's when people fail to sort of make
changes in their life that are
meaningful okay slightly um so we've got
70 people in the team so far at the
moment
let's say as a bit of a full experiment
you were allowed to clone like three of
them oh a million times over and you're
like like if you think of the people
that I like I would clone you in a
heartbeat add to my business what are
the what are the characteristics of
those like clonable top performers oh
um
and I guess I'm asking for someone
listening to this is like you know if
they're in a job and they want to kind
of stand out or join a new job or
anything like that like what are the
things that someone like you would be
looking for as a business owner tenacity
tenacity is at the word where you push
through I think there's not enough
people in businesses that just keep
pushing like even if you get a pushback
no you can't do that or you know it's
going to take time yeah no we'll figure
out another way and I think those are
the people in my business that I go yes
I'm so glad I've got you because I think
people who don't take no for an answer
or don't take pushbacks for an answer
are the ones that succeed 100 so I think
tenacity
um the second thing that I would do is
clone anybody that is super curious so
one of the things I do I test people in
job interviews and I go have you got any
questions and if they go no I don't
think I have
they don't get the job
anybody that wants to be successful or
is you know going to be good at their
job are curious they're gonna have a
million questions and I want a million
questions I want them to ask me Carrie
what do you do day to day or how much
money do you make or you know um what
are the problems in the business or
what's the first thing you would like me
to do or whatever it is people who ask
questions they're the ones that succeed
the most and they're the ones that do
well in things like pitches if they're
asking their clients questions all the
time tell me about this tell me about
that how do I know about this like like
how do I learn as much as possible about
you and your company they're the ones
that succeed so I think those are the
two things that I mainly focus on is
tenacity and curiosity
um and then lastly I think it's just
enthusiasm I think people that are just
every day positive about their job
um I think obviously we're not all
positive you know when I go through days
of negativity no I don't want to really
go to work today whatever it is but I
think if you have a positive outlook
mostly on life I think you can change
the perception of most most things
basically can you think of many people
that you have that have those category
those characteristics but you would
still say are underperforming like is
there a because we've we've talked a
kind of like personality traits tenacity
curiosity and enthusiasm yeah is there
like a kind of tangible performance
element as well that's Decor related
from those things or do you find that it
kind of tends to go together
tends to go together I think there's a
couple of things that I noticed
repeatedly in those people that they
need to improve on usually those people
aren't very good at
um
delegating work they're like protective
over I can do this I can do that you
know they they force through things and
I guess they're not very good at
delegating work down and working as a
team and things like that but overall
they're usually the high performers I
call them the a players everyone has
like businesses have a plays and B
players and I'll not list who they are
today or anything like that I have many
a players and one of the things that I
always say is if you a good business is
based off how many a players they're
having a business so if you have 30
people in your company and
um 15 of them are a players you've got a
very good company
I think people usually have what two 3A
players
um and it's really hard to get them by
the way
um but yeah I I try to aim as many as
possible
and can you tell in an interview that
someone's going to be an a player or is
it like within a couple of months of
seeing them like when when do you find
out usually I can tell in an interview
and it's usually those three traits I
just mentioned and I usually ask them
when was the last time you pushed
through something to that show tenacity
like you didn't take note you didn't
give up
um have you got any questions curiosity
um and then enthusiasm I just asked them
tell me something that you've done
recently and just see how enthusiastic
they tell and you go you just know that
they are going to be your a players and
do you find that that prediction holds
true when when you see them
in real life yes it does the only thing
is a players don't usually stick around
because they become entrepreneurs they
usually go and start their own
businesses and that's what happened with
me I had a lot of people leave and go
start businesses which I'm very proud of
I'm like wow like I hired 100 overall
I've hired 140 people in last three
years and so many of them have gone to
start their own businesses and I'm proud
of that because I remember thinking like
I want my people to work here and go and
work for Netflix or Disney or you know
amazing brands or go start their own
businesses and I'll be very very proud
and that's my success metric if I can go
and create that so yeah the fat people
have gone and started their own
businesses is a good thing but it did
mean that I had to constantly replace
people because they they come they learn
and then they move on and go start their
own thing and so yeah a play is a very
very valuable but they're very hard to
keep what's the balance between
I guess being yourself
versus choosing yourself
in the sense of for me my my default
self you know we talked about how the
self is you know um a result of
accidents of stuff my default behavior
is often to prioritize work at the
expense of everything else I am the
happiest person in the world if I've
spent five hours in the evening on my
laptop from 6 pm to 11 p.m
um but that's not really the person I
want to be I want to be a person who has
more balance who takes care of their
health and their relationships and who
views time spent with loved ones loved
ones not as a
you know I want to I'd rather be on my
laptop but more like a I'm genuinely
happy to be here in the present moment
even so that's that's kind of who I want
to be but it's not who I am if that if
that makes sense so how do we
how do I know which one is more quote
authentic because I find that my mum
often says sometimes that oh you know
Ali you know you're you're trying to
change for other people and stuff this
was when at University I made the active
decision that I wanted to become more
confident and charismatic and be more of
more outgoing whereas in school I was a
massive nerd and played World of
Warcraft all evening yeah and so to my
mum that was the real me and she would
say that you're fine as you are you
don't need to change I'd be like no but
I want to change like I wanna I wanna
level up that's just better I think to
be more confident okay uh yeah what do
you reckon
there is the
conditioned self
and there is true self
there is
the mind and identity
and there is
spirit
what we've come to identify of who we
are is actually the construction of the
Mind
the mind has created an identity we
enter this world and then the mind is
trying to understand
who am I
what does that mean who are you what is
this world how do they all fit together
and it creates an identity and it builds
one
and it builds certain understandings of
the world and what people do and
intentions
and it's mapping out this internal world
and that is down to the accidents of
birth that is down to like you're saying
you know your family your cultural
experiences the place and time in this
universe that we have this opportunity
the mind will always do that then there
is true self which is just consciousness
and the nature of Consciousness is love
is truth
the mind says I need to get everything
in place and then I'll feel at peace the
soul says be at peace and everything
else falls into place
we've been living from our minds for the
majority of Our Lives though
we've been living from that place and
we've built up Armory and we've built up
coping mechanisms to navigate
the path is beginning to
take off some of that Armory
to see that actually when I connect to
truth and love I will
then see what it looks like you don't
need to figure that out
if you can just go down into that place
of Truth and Love
you will see
what it will look like
because one thing we do know is that the
mind is a terrible predictor of what
will make us happy
all these ideas
my life has to look like this it should
look like this and then I'll be happy
we've got no idea
we've got no idea we don't even know
what's going to happen in one minute's
time
so to take away all the configuration
for the mind trying to
even choose or a map or or build or be a
lot of
self-improvement is talking about
improving who you are or optimizing who
you are which is based on the premise
that you are not enough
you're you're not good enough you're not
whole enough you're not
you're not enough so you've got to do
more a change to be better or get being
caught in the same trap
move away from mine down into
Consciousness into that field of
Consciousness tap into that place of
love and into it intuition and move from
that place of Truth and then we'll see
what it looks like
so what does that look like in my
confidence I want to be confident
because I feel like I'm not yet
confident and I would like to be more
that way yes yeah
this idea that you're not confident is
an idea
take away the illusion
and then we'll find truth
so it's
the more that we begin to
drop out of the Mind the more that we
create separation from the mind we'll
just begin to notice oh gosh my mind is
just saying that I'm not confident gosh
my mind has created an identity of of
who I am it's got its idea of who Ali is
and we can be curious about that and see
it from a distance as if you're
observing another person so what is
identity that my mind has created about
Ali
who does my mind say that Ali is what
does my mind say Ali can do in kanji
gosh what does my mind judge that would
be inappropriate for Ali to do
we just begin to see it we begin to see
how the mind created all these
preconceived ideas and Notions oh gosh
it says that he's not confident
the more that we create separation from
it and we fear and distance from it we
will then just be moving from truth and
the truth is
you are neither confident nor not
confident
you just are
you are neither
brilliant nor not brilliant you just are
the mystics would just say I am
that's all we can say I am and there is
no there's no label that we can attach
to something which can capture reality
okay
There's No Label which can accurately
capture
ultimate power and love there's no name
for it it's just pure power you are pure
power you're pure even that's just a
name or an idea but you're just pure
power and and energy
and we'll see where that energy can go
but when we move from that place even
the idea of confident and confident
doesn't make sense anymore
it's like what
you know color is the number seven
and that doesn't make sense that's not
who I am that's not that's not what I am
it's just then more ramblings of the
Mind
you move from that place of power
and you will all that will happen is it
will be unfoldings and you'll just begin
to
if we if we turn the confidence then
into something more concrete like
ability to play finger Style on the
guitar
an ability to play finger finger Style
on the guitar you know that kind of that
kind of music
so that's an ability yeah so you can
accurately assess yeah what is my level
of ability in terms of playing the
guitar
yep and I can choose to actively improve
that ability or increase that ability if
I want to yes
similarly if I like confident is a bit
Dodge but if I were to think instead of
being confident which is like a almost
like a character trait that is has a
value judgment on it because more
confident is generally better uh yes
Society judges but instead of it
thinking at thinking a specific skill of
public speaking while doing
presentations specific ability to go up
to a pretty girl and talk to her
specific ability to
whatever completely those are then areas
in which I can decide okay I actually
wanted to work on my presentation skills
therefore I'm going to watch some
YouTube videos and do some practice yes
but I'm not
using that as a way of thinking
therefore I am currently unconfident
because in a way that also becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy
completely so we can build up individual
skills
and say the the key part though is just
seeing when the mind is making judgments
and being able to see that as
just the nature of your mind which is a
tool
because whenever you live from a place
of
no mind or just live from a place of
presence
you're not even thinking about
confidence or not confident so if I
think about me right now
how am I coming across as confident or
not confident I'd have to make a
judgment of I don't know
like potentially some people might say
yes or no it doesn't matter I just need
to be me this episode is very kindly
brought to you by wework now this is
particularly exciting for me because I
have been a full paying customer of
wework for the last two years now I
discovered it during you know when the
pandemic was in the on the verge of
being lifted and I'd spent like the
whole year just sort of sitting in my
room making YouTube videos but then I
discovered wework and I was a member of
me and Angus my team members we were
members of the wework in Cambridge and
they have like hundreds of other
locations worldwide as well and it was
incredible because we had this fantastic
beautifully designed office space to go
to to work and we found ourselves like
every day just at nine o'clock in the
morning just going to wework because it
was a way nicer experience working from
the co-working space than it was just
sitting at home working these days what
me and everyone on my team has is the
all access pass which means you're not
tied to a specific wework location but
it means you can use any of their
several hundred co-working spaces around
London around the UK and also around the
world and one of the things I really
love about the co-working setup is that
it's fantastic as a bit of a change of
scenery so these days I work from home
I've got the studio at home but if I
need to get some focused writing work
done and I've been I'm feeling a bit
drain just sitting at my desk all day
I'll just pop over to the local wework
which is about a 10 minute walk from
where I am I'll take my laptop with me
I'll get some free coffee from there
I'll get a few snacks and it's just such
a great Vibe and you get to meet cool
people I've made a few friends through
meeting them at wework and it's just
really nice being in an environment
almost like a library but kind of nicer
because there's like a little bit of
soft music in the background and there's
other kind of startup Bros and creators
and stuff in in there as well and it's
just my absolute favorite co-working
space of all time it's super easy to
book a desk or book a conference room
using the app and it's a great place to
meet up with team members if you're
going to collaborate and you'll live in
different places they've got unlimited
tea and coffee and herbal teas and
drinks on tap and they've got soundproof
booths in which they take Zoom calls and
meetings anyway if you're looking for a
co-working space for you or your team
then I'd 100 recommend we work like I
said I've been a pain customer for
theirs for the last two years which is
why it's particularly exciting that
they're now sponsoring this episode and
if you want to get 50 off your first
booking then do head over to we.com
forward slash Ali and you can use the
coupon code Ali at checkout Ali to get
50 off your first booking so thank you
so much wework for sponsoring this
episode there's a blog post you wrote uh
I can't remember color of the time seven
I probably like 2010 or something and
you said something like uh the the
advice that you give to students when
they're trying to figure out what to do
with their careers is to begin with the
lifestyle in mind and reverse engineer
the career from that rather than hey I
did an economics degree therefore uh
private Equity hedge funds or Investment
Banking are my three options and you end
up going down one of these one of these
routes
um and that that post really vibed with
me because I think it helped it made me
think Hmm if I were to begin with a
lifestyle in mind does that in fact
actually look like the big Media Company
um the answer is probably not but then
another part of me was like am I just
feeling
uh am I just bullshitting myself and
just like setting my ambitions lower
because I am afraid of the work that it
would take to build said Media company
and try and try and go big and I'm just
content to wallow in my own mediocrity
of like oh I'll just write four hours a
day and then I'm happy with life I don't
need to make that much money and you do
you get what I'm getting up yeah I don't
think you're dilute so first of all I
love that post so yeah Lifestyle Center
Career planning I think is such a
critical idea
um especially for young people trying to
figure out like in college I wrote that
while at a graduation ceremony for my
sister so I was thinking about graduate
graduation advice yeah and you and it it
has to be the right answer for how you
figure out your career which is you get
the image of the lifestyle you want at
whatever point you know in the future
and you make it super tangible like you
can you can feel it you can smell it you
can see it but not getting specific at
all about what your work is like are you
in the countryside are you in a city is
it you know you're you're at the
Bohemian bar in the in the Lower East
Side and and around all these artists
are you in a field and you've been out
in the sun and like you know whatever
working on your Trails like what is it
is it very social are you in a small
town are you what are you up in the
mountains like get that really clear and
then say great let me work backwards now
to figure out how do I get there with my
work
right and and I think that's such a
critical way of thinking about things
because hey it's not just hey Follow
Your Passion or something like this
because the right answer might be I'm
going to go to medical school so that I
can be uh sort of get these Nightingale
shifts where I work uh three times a
week one week out of the month or
something like that or work for three
months and it's and it's the highest
hourly rate I can get and then I can
spend the whole summer in the Canary
Islands like it it can lead you to
really interesting places I think it's
the way to do it and the reason why I
think you in particular are not you're
not deluding yourself into you know
avoiding the difficulties of ambition is
that
a lot of people when they do this
exercise it is 100 clear they want that
they really crave that activity and work
right so I think it's a really clear
personality type thing that that if you
are the type of person whose ideal
lifestyle does involve I've got a team
I'm making moves it's super really clear
if you talk to those people and I have
because you know this is my framework
and I run that framework past there's a
lot of people who are like I love the
idea of activity and I want to be doing
something I want people you know I want
to be at the center of attention I want
people that are on my team I want to be
I love that action the sociality the the
some people love that so
if you don't feel it unambiguous of
course that's what I want to do
then I think that's really meaningful
and I'll tell you I think I'm like you
which is why the way I am logistically
handling the business aspect of all this
career is right now I have a half day
rule
one half day a week it has to fit in
that if it can't if something can't fit
in that then I can't do it and my goal
down the line is make that one day a
week what is slow productivity
broadly so yeah so if we don't have
here's the issue with knowledge work in
general
the issue we've been grappling with in
the last 20 minutes like what does
productivity even mean right and and so
then it just becomes this weird
catch-all or Boogeyman so I have this
thought of like why don't we actually
positively come out and come up with a
definition that we like a definition
that's human a definition that that
melds well with our human instincts and
the way our brain is actually wired
that's centered around producing
meaningful and valuable things but in a
way that's very sustainable in a way
that's very satisfying so so instead of
just pushing Back Against The Boogeyman
productivity like let's put in place an
alternative and the alternative I've
been working on is called slow
productivity and like the slow food
movement or these other movements I've
I've gone back and pulled from these
sort of existing cultures of knowledge
workers that have been around for
centuries in some cases Millennia that
had the privilege and space to kind of
figure out what's the best way to work
with your mind you know what works what
doesn't and figuring out can we have a
widely applicable definition of
productivity comes out of it and so slow
productivity has three principles to it
do fewer things
working at a natural pace
obsessing over quality
like those three things approaching
knowledge work with those three
principles
realigns the efforts with our Humanity
the way we're wired I can give you a
neuroscience argument for it I can give
you a psychological argument for it I
can give you a philosophical argument
for those three things it all on all
three of those levels
orienting knowledge work around that is
Meaningful satisfying you can produce
things a great value it can be very
productive for companies they can be
very satisfying for individuals so I'm
sort of putting together my pitch of
what what Target of productivity should
people who make a living using their
brains what it what should they be going
for Beyond just you know
get after it have your to-do's organized
I don't know what's what's the
philosophical argument
well there's uh like we go back to
Aristotle if we need to right there's
this the what what is the the teleology
of of human existence well what's the
one thing we have that other creatures
don't is we have these brains that can
sit and think and create things
um and there's there's a there's a
there's an argument towards the the
production of things of value and
meaning and sort of giving things the
time they require craftsmanship that
there's there's a real philosophical
Foundation to the human value that's
extracted from actually like doing
things of of value of impact with your
mind and a lot of that gets sapped away
when you're just answering emails all
day uh or just hustling to get after it
you could go all the way back to neuro I
mean this is the the thing I'm working
on now is I I've gone back heavily to do
a deep into the mainly social
anthropological research to do a deep
history of work
for 300 000 years what was work for
humans because that's a long enough time
span that our brain
evolved right the the match this
definition of work and you know surprise
surprise when you go back and look
through this deep literature you see
not doing too many things
sees a variation in Pace and intensity a
lot of your time being the application
of hard one skills like that's exactly
what comes up that's what we did for 300
000 years so there's also this almost
like psychology anthropological even
neuroscientific argument for not being
overloaded varying your intensity in
various ways and spending more of your
time like applying hard-won skills like
what we expect work to be
do you have you stumbled across any kind
of
um Dunbar number for number of active
projects that one should have at a given
time like when you say fewer things I
mean how few are we talking
well yeah I mean I so there's two
different time scales I mean at the
scale of like what you're working on
right now it's one right so like in the
what what we cannot do what our brain
cannot do is concurrently during like
the afternoon go back and forth between
three different things
it just the way our planning motivation
Loop works like we have one thing in our
working memory we build this internal
model that pulls episodic memories out
of the hippocampus we use that to try to
predict what we should do next that
system cannot handle more than one thing
so we cannot be thinking about making
decisions on or making progress on more
than one thing at a time and I don't
mean like literally at the time like
over a couple hours even like work on
one thing till you're done move on to
the other thing our brain cannot go back
and forth It's why email like going back
and forth between your email just
crushes us psychologically uh you know a
recent podcast episode I talked about
task freeze where you see like 15 things
you need to do and you just stop it's
because you literally the planning
motivational Center of your brain can't
make plans for 15 things at the same
time it neurologically can't do that so
your motivation system just freezes up
right so at a time one thing in terms of
like ongoing projects I'm a big believer
in like pull-based methodology where
there's like two or three things you're
two or three things you're working on
when something finishes you can pull
something else in
you know and I actually think this is
how companies should organize work
software developers already do this but
I think we should do this more broadly
in knowledge work where yeah there's a
lot of work the company needs to do
don't just distribute that to everyone's
plate and everyone has 20 things that
they have to kind of figure out what to
do with they should just be working on a
couple things and they can pull in new
things once they're once it's ready and
the problem why you need well I think
this is important and why I think it's
killer to have a lot of things on your
plate even if you're not working on them
at the exact same time is that there's
something called an overhead tax that
every project that you have committed to
generates it's a overhead of
administrative work that you have to do
even if you're not actively working on
the project it's emails you have to send
meetings planning meetings standing
meetings you have to have and just
cognitive load of knowing it's there so
that builds up so if you have 15
projects on your plate you're paying
overhead tax on 15 projects and that tax
takes up your time and before you know
it most of your time mental energy is
going to the maintenance of the ongoing
project and almost nothing gets done and
then you fall farther behind and then
the the more projects build up and the
tax gets worse I call it the overhead
spiral it's a terrible state to be in so
there's a real cost to having too many
things on your plate even if you're very
careful about this morning I'm just
working on this and then in the
afternoon I'm just working on that and
on Tuesdays I work on this once you get
past a certain level it's a problem and
I think again it's something companies
get wrong they just say let's distribute
the task informally to everyone we'll
have everything live on people's
individual plates and they can just
figure out what to work on and whatnot
and the overhead text kills them like a
much better system is this all sits in a
holding tank
and when I'm ready for the next thing I
pull it in but until it leaves that
holding tank I'm paying no overhead tax
on it it's not actually it's not
actually my view so I honestly think
like three active projects at a time is
best and obviously when you're working
on something you're only working on that
one thing all right so that's it for
this week's episode of Deep dive thank
you so much for watching or listening
all the links and resources that we
mentioned in the podcast are going to be
linked down in the video description or
in the show notes depending on where
you're watching or listening to this if
you're listening to this on a podcast
platform then do please leave us a
review on the iTunes Store it really
helps other people discover the podcast
or if you're watching this in full HD or
4k on YouTube then you can leave a
comment down below and ask any questions
or any insights or any thoughts about
the episode that would be awesome and if
you enjoyed this episode you might like
to check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye